[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for another tour of cities that I
haven't done in [ __ ] years um I don't
even know what I'm driving right now
this is one of the worst [ __ ] cars
look back at this car there's there's no
backup camera I can't see [ __ ] with a
little side wonder there
I've almost almost took out this guy in
a bike and he [ __ ] freaked out on me
this what the [ __ ] are you doing I want
to be able I'm doing what you would be
doing if you were in a car you know I'm
not paying attention I made a [ __ ]
car so anyways I'm in Phoenix Arizona
look at it's just a sports town yeah
that's mean like sorry I bet if you got
a sports town here this is one of the
worst names for an arena I've seen in a
while
Talking Stick resort Arena
let's go down to the talking sticks
[ __ ] resort arena that sounds like
you're gonna get like a massage or
something
get a parking garage they up here you
got your Chase Field
it's where the I wanted to say Devil
Rays but it's the Diamondbacks
this is you know what I like about that
place whenever I Drive by there that's
where they beat the Yankees in not in
2001 when even I as a Red Sox fan
because it was right after 9/11 I was
like I [ __ ] over please
I'll root for him you know it's good for
the city and then they lost and so first
good feelin I had at post 9/11 watchin
em loose this is this weird thing about
this the city out here was the second
like you need the downtown area it just
immediately becomes like Roadrunner
Kyushu should I head back towards the
downtown area oh you know it's big out
here dogs getting out Jesus Christ like
that guys base is so [ __ ] his big out
here is this other than really loud bass
in the truck behind says literally
making my ears itch I don't I came to
this part of beer
it was funny about that it's shaking his
whole car and he's just like just
[ __ ] up his suspension all of it is
just just gradually coming loose it's
like he's driving over a pothole let me
sit still why would you have it that
loud dude I got a [ __ ] sick sound
system not even a bass player would have
to face that luck you know you don't
hear the other instruments is there
anything worse than a bass solo
you can't [ __ ] hear it remember Billy
sheet him would always [ __ ] after
Steve Vai and David Lee ruff Steve I
would be with all his [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then he come up and basically do the
same thing which is like what the [ __ ]
anyway so what's a big thing out here is
little dogs going missing you can't
leave the gate open out here there's
just too many yo to me coyotes snakes I
don't know what the [ __ ] gets the Mafia
pedophiles little there's always a
sexual predator on that does it right I
think this is the number one place that
sexual predators after they get out of
jail you know this is where they usually
settle down into downtown Phoenix area
it's like looking at all sweaty kids I
don't know why I'm saying that I'm sorry
my vision
not over years we all write a country
song about a guy he was Stevie steep we
sing about him and his dad flying f-15s
bad blue or Hampton beans it's like no
you didn't know you didn't they would
never let that accent into that's
[ __ ] billion dollar aircraft whatever
it cost you no remember Top Gun
nobody had a southern accent and that
did they all those Chippendales looking
guys they all had like the Midwest
accent didn't they you know it's funny I
actually like this place but there's
just nothing one oh my god Jesus Christ
that's just a whole lot of lovin don't
don't don't don't show his head my god
dude he was dressed like a toddler he
basically had on a onesie all right now
we're getting a real Phoenix I showed
you the nice air here we go I think I
saw that No Country for Old Men blew
this but dumped McDonald's they don't
even have a playground I have this here
this is the America that Trump connected
with right
alright there's a guy sitting in the
back of a pickup truck I mean this is
like this guy's little engine hobo back
in the days he be riding in boxcars but
I guess trains don't exist anymore
I love it you're afraid he keeps
catching us you got to know if you're
sitting in the back of that lady's
drinking out of his joke you're looking
at a guy that guy has no social security
number so you had everybody perfectly
good white guy look what happened you
make the wrong decisions in life you
know you end up in the back of a pickup
truck in Phoenix Arizona just hanging on
for dear life
[ __ ] guy with a metal detector it was
a weed whip oh I comes a metal detector
loan Max cash loans on car titles Jesus
Christ how does that even work to come
down you can have your title in your car
I'm gonna take my title in there in
exchange for cash and then I'm gonna go
to the track that's what I'm gonna do
there you go horizontal strikes
horizontal stripes he's like in his body
something about being broken this just
typing meat it just [ __ ] beats the
[ __ ] out of you dude is there one color
in this area that does not look stolen
oh here we go
we're breaking out of urban sprawl
here's the landfill this is the end of
this is the end of this [ __ ] all right
here we go
uplifting look at this poor bastard
walking to work because he brought his
title down because he went to the track
little riverbed here some Clint Eastwood
[ __ ] right Pale Rider why would you
advertise Brooklyn bedding here but
people have [ __ ] sleeping on the
ground maybe it's for the all the people
like me driving through it right
all those privileged people you guys
like that it wore a sweater this is my
new thing to keep myself calm I wear
sweaters weird Angie's you know para
shell toes for a little flair
and this is a Duke Blue Devil hat you
know I know some of you gonna be like
when the [ __ ] did you become a fan yeah
how about three weeks ago when I went to
again it was phenomenal look at that
right there
that's something Richard Rawlings would
buy on gas monkey garage
monkey walked up to that and even he
always has the other guy talk first and
you know just be like so what are you
thinking I was like 10 grand okay I'm a
Cantonese Lodi what are you thinking
I mean I was thinking like four is where
they grow all their weep
is weed legal in Arizona there's no way
it's there's no they don't even
celebrate living celebrate Martin Luther
King Day there's no way they let you
smoke a joint pawn shops are so [ __ ]
overrated
pawn shops are so overrated when you
watch was it what's it a pawn show pawn
stuff on star yeah when you watch Pawn
Stars you think you're gonna go in there
there's gonna be like a Super Bowl ring
you're like a Indian motorcycle then you
get in there it's just it's like a Casio
keyboard somebody's old apron it's like
where is all the good [ __ ] cars twos
silver what does that say cold guns
what gold gold gold guns gold space guns
oh look Rajyam almost had a rough week
like I believe that's a hospital if you
get sick I guess you go over there you
know as you do that's the [ __ ] worst
there's no way when I get older there's
no way I'm going I'm not I'm not the
pain in a hospital I'm [ __ ] dying and
then listening to the respirator or the
person next to me but that smell I hate
hospitals
I got no you know I got my affairs in
order and one of them is just like you
know when I'm in a bad way pull the
[ __ ] plug
I'd have to be laying there like in that
Metallica video everybody's [ __ ]
talking about me I don't I think I saw
it both his toe can you hear my voice in
there I'm just thinking on a loop all
they kill me kill me kill me I don't
care if I'm going to help let's just get
it let's just get on with it
ready to meet the devil what could be
worse than just laying there in your
[ __ ] head you know raise you feel
yourself dying oh good I feel myself I'm
starting to die and that you just feel
injecting nutrition into your arm can
you cry when you're in a coma
can that happen
what if that's a good taco hey let's
find a good place to get something this
this you want to get a taco inventive
burritos invented burrito means a white
guys make Mexican infused what do they
have against cutting the grass out in
these [ __ ] desert place Church's
Chicken KFC autozone Big Ben Parliament
it's the same [ __ ] twelve stores you
don't it is about broke areas in the
southwest versus the east coast is at
least like the land is lush back on the
East Coast like this [ __ ] just looks so
[ __ ] dead it's like tumbleweeds and
stuff it just looks extra broke my dad's
[ __ ] in 15 so yeah just love you
cowboy hat on
there's like a thing if you fly like f50
Joe so I have to be like good-looking
you can't come in there with that
[ __ ] country bumpkin
[ __ ] you got to lose that accent get
yourself a little high and tight haircut
go in there with your [ __ ] cowboy
boots you know dude it's those [ __ ]
lunatics after all those years of riding
bulls and shooting wild boar they put
them on that little [ __ ] one of us
that ride the centrifuge Turkish twist
whatever they put them in your face
starts doing this [ __ ] you know they
just said they going where it's gonna
take a lot more a lot more than that you
know going around in a circle to scare a
redneck get out of me they putting
dynamite no lawn mowers blowing their
legs off you seen that video
blew my leg off this guy blows this leg
off and that's what he says I blew my
leg off that's it where's this screaming
Oh get out get your bellies is that a
blooper leg off probably call this mom
Bob
mom's key i'm luben leg off no I'm not
gonna hold let's try and think of a good
cowboy name is Jesse a bloomer let it go
Jesse won't be here today he blew his
leg off shooting in an old tractor
that's what this guy did he had an old
[ __ ] tractor he filled it up with
this explosive and there's some sort of
like you know ratio for whatever pounds
of explosives the amount of feet you
have to be away from it and he didn't do
that you know like when you put together
something you just throw the directions
out he did that with like [ __ ]
dynamite and he's stuck in an old mom
[ __ ] no riding mower just that blade
alone if that came flying at you would
take your [ __ ] head up and he's
standing you know like he already shot
something and now he's just going for
the kill shot just walked right up to it
shoots the thing your camera goes like
that he falls down he just goes a blew
my leg off
you got to tell that story for the rest
of your [ __ ] life how'd you lose your
leg we in Fallujah now I put a bunch of
dynamite in an old tractor and I was Bob
seven eight feet away from it I started
shooting at it and you know it blew up
and it took my leg with it was it
painful
oh yeah oh yeah who are you screaming
now what'd you do I just stated the
obvious
I'm blew my leg off
it's like an endless character I'm gonna
come in your mouth no he'd say it after
came in your mouth oh there's a [ __ ]
hotel we did it yeah yeah it was perfect
this really isn't a tour as much as up
telling stories because there's nothing
to see here this is one of these areas
when they just put a bunch of shops and
they try to get human beings to sort of
gather we'll put an urban outfitter as
an anchor store they won't have a
Chipotle what else do people like to do
I don't know man I just always been a
truth-teller
if there's just true playing on the
table I just got to say it my balls
stuck to my leg can I start with a salad
the overshare guy chipotle there you go
that's all the jogging that fat people
do they run they try to make a like to
go into Chipotle I'm kidding they were
gonna see this oh oh stand up look at
stand up life comedy theater
but from what I heard it's one of the
biggest comedy clubs one of the biggest
Kylie Clemson North American tours he's
[ __ ] hilarious
this shit's amped up above dude you know
what I like you don't like I like
mustard is there anything better than
mustard on a sandwich Mae it's crazy
it's great literally like it's the
listener it's like where do I take that
conversation well gee Paul what do you
think about mayonnaise don't like it not
a mayonnaise guy just a sandwich